بمناسبة حقول بارك ميونغسونغ ، في 26 فبراير ، زار قصر كومسوسان للشمس ، وكانت البذور
بعد 20000 وون ، أعضاء اللجنة الدائمة للمكتب السياسي ، وأعضاء المرشحين لحزب المفوض السامي السياسي.
وشاركت منظمة صون القيادية المركزية
مع الهجرة كشعار لك ،
الأم التي لا يستطيع التاريخ فعلها هي للعظيمة Chang-Goo ، التي عاشت حياتها كلها كالنار.
محادثات شوق جون سوران لكوريا متعرجة إلى ما لا نهاية ، والنصيحة هي قصر كومسوسان للشمس ، فضية عشرات الآلاف
لقد علقت في الغلاف الجوي
[موسيقى]
جدا
تمثال الرفيق جيم إيل سيونغ ، تنين الماء العظيم ، والرفيق كيم سونغ آي ، بحجم ميديان تقريبًا.
هدأت سلة الملابس التي قدمها الخادم للرفيق كيم سونغ إيون.
[موسيقى]
اللجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري الذي أطلق النار على المسلح استقال من منصب رئيس وزراء لجنة الأسلحة لجمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية.
إنجولا بناء المعلومات الشعبية P اللجنة الدائمة في
وقال بوب إنه حيث تم الوفاء بأمر جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية الأولى
منجز
[موسيقى]
16 2 في النصف الأول من السنة ، كان الرب مع المشتركين.
2d وظيفة المذاب Jeongdong تلتقط تمثال زعيم Midianite الرفيق Kim Jong-il Huck عدة
المرشح ليس جيدا فربته وأعطيته بذرة.
الرفيق الذي استخدم المجموعات الطوعية لمديان ، أخذ استراحة من حياته السابقة.
ابحث عني وسأبني نفسي هنا.
الناس في بلادنا في الظلام ، يستمعون إلى أوامر الرئيس ، الأحمق ران ، وشول جو الخاص بي.
أصبح المركز عصر التأسيس
في منتصف الليل ، صنع مدفع رشاش Anjido ورقة حلم لمساعدة الرفاق في لائحة الاتهام
علاقة
لقطات المشاهير المعرفة بالاتصالات الجوية الشاملة والوقوف بقوة حتى المنافسة الصفرية في المنع
بيعت للتو وراء اللجنة المركزية للنشاط G2 للغرفة
[موسيقى]
أوو